I'm thrilled that he accepted my
invitation to call into this program
because I always enjoyed watching his
work in his years in the National
Football League ninth all-time in
catches 14th all-time in yards
he's got 82 touchdowns to his credit
that's just the regular season he had a
touchdown catch in the Ravens victory in
the Super Bowl back in Super Bowl xlvii
but most importantly he's co-founder of
players coalition he's joining us right
here on the Rich Eisen show he is
Anquan Boldin how are you sir I am doing
better for talking to you I thank you
for saying yes to this invitation to
come on here Walter Payton NFL man of
the year in 2015 I should also mention
that Anquan Boldin what is going through
your mind today
Anquan it's a big macro question but I
would love to know what's in your mind
in your heart at this very moment as you
call it to the show big question Mike I
think I'm at a point now with what's
going on in our country I'm trying to
pinpoint the problems that we've
continued to come across time and time
again in this country obviously you have
to be sleeping on the rock in order to
not know what's going on in our country
right now especially with you know what
happened with mr. Floyd what happened
with Brianna Taylor and Ahmad oddly
recently and the thing that that keeps
coming back is how does this keep
happening and how does it keep happening
without accountability and I think
that's a question that I've been looking
at and trying to answer and I think for
so long we've missed a mark we are
talking about you know community
policing we're talking about body
cameras we're talking about all of these
solutions and none of them hit the mark
and you can do all of the community
policing you want and you have a
situation let's just say you do
community policing for ten years and you
have a situation like what happened in
many yet Minneapolis happen all of the
work that you've done and your
department has done for the last 10
years with Community Police and goes out
the window when there is no
accountability for what's happening and
the reason I say that is because there's
a fight in this country that had to be
had a lot of people have avoided that
fight and the fight that I'm talking
about is qualified immunity that's the
thing that nobody is talking about so
let's talk about it what do you mean by
that
Anquan cuz again we're sure as you're
saying this we're showing streets of
this this nation we're also seeing
internationally the attention that is
being brought to the matter at hand and
in a way that I think it feels
unprecedented to me but again I'm a 50
year old white guy um III I want to what
do you mean by that so now that there's
potentially more attention being paid
here right so what I mean by that is
there is language and number one at
Supreme Court and there is language in
union contracts that allows for officers
to not be held accountable so number one
and in the Supreme Court which is
actually something that I think people
are starting to look more into azzam
recently is the immunity piece from
the Supreme Court which no government
official and I think government
officials especially one of the things
that that's really jacked up is
prosecutors like attorney your state's
attorney and the District Attorney's
these prosecutors who have complete
immunity meaning no matter what they do
they're not held accountable and I'll
give you an example of right so take the
amount are be case for example mm-hmm
there were what three prostitute errs on
that case and the first prosecutor did
not law enforcement from arresting those
two guys to make Michaels right and then
it came to light that there was a
conflict of interest that first
prosecutor had they would choose
themselves and then she passed it to
another prosecutor who she knew would do
the exact same thing that she was going
to do and luckily we found out that
there was a conflict of interest with
the second prosecutor which means he had
to recuse himself now before he recused
himself he tried to take that case by
saying I found them doing no wrong they
were well within their rights to be
doing what they did they are innocent
and he was out of line for doing that he
was against the law for doing that but
because he and the first prosecutor has
immunity complete immunity nothing will
be done against them nothing will be
done to hold them accountable now let's
go to law enforcement or police a lot of
people don't know that there are
contracts between cities and the unions
the pollution and there are
there's a lot of languages in the
contract that allow for offers to
officers to go unpunished
every every contract has different
language in it but there's two parts to
those contracts there's one part that
talks about the financing and then
there's a second part that talks about
the disc the discipline and that's where
we as a nation have to start looking
because what kind of system allows an
officer with 18 prior complaint two of
them being shootings to continue to be
on the force Anquan Boldin here on the
Rich Eisen show co-founder of players
coalition so let's give somebody out
there who's saying I want to do
something I want to call somebody so it
is there again I'm sure we could fill
three hours with this is there I guess a
way for somebody to educate themselves
on what they should be calling a
representative of theirs for and to do
is there a a cheat sheet is there
something that you have that people can
go learn is there one that you want to
bring up here that I guess other than
what you just mentioned actionable items
that you think someone should be
undertake Anquan Boldin I think there
are a lot of actionable items because
unfortunately we we don't have a justice
system we have a legal system and legal
systems are completely different than
justice systems so when we're talking
about actionable items I think one of
the easiest things to do is number one
to register people to vote but to also
educate people on
why you're voting who you're voting for
and what they stand behind so a lot of
people don't understand like when you go
in to vote there's more than just your
president or you know there are a lot of
people on those ballots a lot of people
who a lot of times you hear nothing
about right there will be District
Attorney races all across this country
there will be share races all across
this country there will be Circuit Court
Judge races all across this country yes
you will have your presidential election
but your local elections are those
people who directly impact you on a
daily basis and I would challenge people
to not only find out who those people
are but find out what their job entails
and find out what policies they stand
behind players - coalition org is the
website for your for your coalition
Anquan Boldin here on the Rich Eisen
show what is your relationship with the
NFL and how hand-in-hand potentially the
NFL as you know received a ton of flack
over the weekend to put out a statement
in support of a lot of what you've just
mentioned I wonder what your
relationship is with the league that you
spent so many years in Anquan the
players coalition word were entirely
separate entity from the NFL the players
Coalition is a players led initiative
that is fighting all of the injustice in
this country and we we stand on four
different pillars on education economic
advancement criminal justice reform and
police community relations and for us
those are the four places where we
where we placed our efforts on trying to
combat the injustice is that that
happened in this country so is there a
role do you think that sports can play
here not just the NFL I mean and and
what what a fleet scan do here to start
the conversation because we all know the
conversation that's been had over the
last 24 hours involves Drew Brees his
comments for which he has apologized I I
wonder what your thoughts on that
subject are Anquan I think sports could
play a huge role what I think in order
for for that to happen like people have
to be to be open and honest I think a
lot of times you know we we beat around
the bush on certain subjects we're not
completely honest about things that go
on and then you know the conversation I
keep hearing people saying there's a
there's a conversation that needs to be
heard and I think we I don't know that's
the right way to say because I think we
all know what the problem is all right
so it's not so much of a conversation
and I'm at the point now where I'm kind
of tired of talking and I'm more about
putting action to what it is that we're
talking about because we can we can talk
all day about what needs to happen but
until there is a strategy and a concrete
plan and action being carried out then
in the talking part is just that talking
have you thought of running for office
yourself no once at all why is that I
mean I just haven't um for me it's about
helping helping those that don't have a
voice and I know we say you know you can
do that from office but a lot of times
when people get in office they seem to
be handcuffed
with what they can do so I think it's
important to especially for people like
myself athletes entertainers whatever
anybody with a plastic or some type of
influence to number one expose what's
happening in our country because I think
for far too long we have we have to
shine a light on those things that are
truly the problem those people that are
truly the problem and I think until we
do that and deal with the real issues
we're going to contain and unfortunately
if we don't we're going to be right back
here again because you have to
understand this isn't the first time
this has happened this isn't the first
time people in America have protested
this has gone on throughout our history
and people are outraged for quite some
time
and then it seems like everybody gets
back to their normal way of doing things
and I hate I would hate for this moment
to pass and there not be any type of
change come about from it because we're
at a pivotal point in our country either
we're gonna fight this or we're not
either we're against this or we're going
to accept it so we're at a point right
now where we have to decide as a country
what are we going to do are we going to
truly be about change or always just
going to offer lip service and make
people feel comfortable
until this happens again if you were in
the locker room the virtual locker room
of the Saints today Anquan Boldin what
would you say to Drew Brees honestly
I've heard about what Jubilee said I
don't I don't know um and honestly I've
tried to stay away from the media like I
said for me I'm trying to come up with
solutions so I don't I don't honestly
know um the whole group
the situation so I'm kind of I really
don't know well I mean again the reason
why I I bring it up is because again he
is one of the most uh obviously know
this famous individuals that the sport
has and his statement was talking about
never agreeing with somebody who would
kneel on the flag and that's again part
of the conversation that I think you
said you know you wish you didn't have
to keep having cuz you're done wanting
to do anything but get actionable items
on the table so that's the reason why I
bring it up and and clearly that
conversation needs to be had with
somebody who does have a lot of
influence if he can bring it to bear for
something that you need to be brought to
bear that's why I I bring it up Anquan
yes so he said he doesn't agree with
people kneeling well it was he's at he
was asked by a reporter again you want
to in in I'll play the sound bite for
you to make sure that I don't just
paraphrase it but again he was asked you
know if everything that's going on right
now in the world would cause players to
kneel again and what would happen in the
NFL if that happened and this was his
response well well I will I will never
agree with anybody disrespecting the
flag of the United States of America or
our country let me let me just tell you
what I see or what I feel when the
national anthem is played and when I
look at the the flag of the United
States I envision my two grandfathers
who fought for this country during World
War two one in the army and one of the
Marine Corps both risking their lives to
protect our country and to try to make
our country and this world a better
place so every time I stand with my hand
over my heart looking at that flag and
singing the national anthem that's what
I think about and in many cases it
brings me to tears thinking about all
that he's been sacrificed not just those
in the military but for that matter
those throughout the civil rights
movement
of the 60s and everyone and all that has
been endured by so many people up until
this point and is everything right with
our country right now no it's not we
still have a long way to go but I think
what you do by standing there and
showing respect to the flag with your
hand over your heart is it shows unity
it shows that we are all in this
together we can all do better and then
we are all part of the solution
he has since apologized for offending
with the comments Anquan I do want to
say that first off devours if I were in
that locker room I would tell you
unfortunately you have not been
listening and so from the moment players
started milling they had to repeatedly
say it's not about the national anthem
it's not about the flag and players have
told you why they are kneeling and I
think every time somebody did an
interview they first started off by
saying it's not about the flag it's not
about the flag it's not about the anthem
it's about African American black men
and women dying far too often at the
hands of law enforcement so if you took
what you just said from the
conversations that we've been having
over the last couple years
number one you haven't been listening at
all to what your brothers in the locker
room have been saying and you're trying
to tell a group of people how they
should handle
the end justices that have been
happening to them since the the
beginning of this country and that's
that's that's disheartening and it makes
you wonder are you really about trying
to bring about change or did you just
want things to be comfortable in the way
that you do this because I can't see
something happening to a person and that
person crying out to me for help and
then I tell that person number one how
they should feel and number two how they
should react I can't tell a rape victim
how they should act after they've been
raped I can't tell them how they should
feel after they've been raped if I'm
truly trying to help that that person I
have to listen and I have to have some
form of empathy and I have to step
outside of myself outside of my shoes in
order to really understand what's going
in going on in their lives because if
I'm not a rape victim I never I would
never know or never understand what that
person is dealing with and how can I say
I'm truly trying to help them if I'm
telling them how to deal with it well
apparently that's part of the
conversations that being had with the
Saints today
Anquan and I just wanted to place that
in front of you because again at some
point everybody's got to come together
and we all have to fight this thing
together and that's one of the many
reasons why I wanted to have you on here
today to give people who are out there I
guess before I let you go on with your
day and again appreciate you calling
what what can people do one more time an
actionable item to leave everybody with
ain't one so like I said earlier there's
a lot of actionable items um looking so
we can be on your podcast for hours
yes talking about things to do um again
it's important that we vote it's
important that we educate ourselves on
who we're voting for
what their position is Kerry what their
job entails and the policies that they
stand behind it's also important for us
to hold those that are in positions in
power accountable like I said if we if
we fail to do that we will continue to
be in this place if we continue to allow
law enforcement to walk away with
qualified immunity then we're going to
be in this place again if we continue to
allow a system that had officers with 18
complaints against them continue to be
on the force we will be here again if we
allow those those complaints against
officers to not be made public will be
here again and these are the things that
are going on that people are not talking
about government officials like
prosecutors having complete immunity no
matter how how many times they break the
law they're not held criminally
responsible so the only thing we have we
can be especially for prosecutors they
are elected officials so we have to know
who our prosecutors are who our DEA than
who our state attorneys are we have to
know the policies that they stand behind
and when they don't do the job the right
way we have to make sure that we vote
these people out Anquan thank you for
the time I appreciate it again your your
co-founder Malcolm Jenkins said quite a
video of
what we just talked about with Drew
Brees and and he's been on before and
and I can't get enough of my
conversations with him despite him going
to an inferior school of higher learning
in Ohio State
yes I actually did that and I appreciate
you joining as well what you and Malcolm
are doing are is just nothing short of
amazing and remarkable and I appreciate
you taking the time oh no problem thanks
well well
you got it Antoine that's Anquan Boldin
here on the Rich Eisen show Walter
Payton Man of the Year Award winner and
obviously somebody who is about it